I want to take you behind the scenes for
a second because moments after Nick and
Kelly came by for ugly dolls then in
walks Charlize Theron and Seth Rogen
because they were there to talk about
their romantic comedy long shot and
speaking of long shots remember that
dating bombshell that Charlie's dropped
on me in Vegas well clearly we had some
unfinished business okay we talked in
Vegas and you said you know I know you
know no I did this to myself you're
Charlie's that's just you so you know
for the average guy it's a long shot
it really isn't I've been single for ten
years it's not a long shot
somebody just needs to grow a pair and
step up I'm cinema computer link anybody
good hi Charlie just from Kansas City I
do have a pair I am so what we want you
to do is will you sign a picture brick
does yes Charlie's came to play she
ancef hook up in their new rom-com long
shot Charlize is running for president
but her advisors believe party animal
Seth will sink her chances for win but
have you ever done something and then
realized oh crap that's gonna go viral
no I did all of my crazy crap before
this social media phones
I would not be working yeah you know you
have been in a romantic comedy before
mm-hmm which one that thing you do oh
yes it's all in smooth yes yes
[Music]
Bob elated by the fact that I'm obsessed
with Tommy really yeah I wanted to be
Daryl Hannah I get that I get
[Music]
[Applause]